[Musique]
y'a pas si longtemps si on voulait boire
de l'eau d'érable il fallait aller à la
cabane décrocher le saut de la haie bien
maintenant on n'a qu'à aller à
l'épicerie plus la cabane y est rendu en
nous allons faire voter aujourd'hui
3au d'érable à l'uqam à montréal on est
allé en terrier les érables en oeuvre de
sucre et l'eau pour lui sur du syvofa on
a mission d'adp et tetra pak vous
excuser mais les produits d'érable en
sirop d'érable
je me concédé comment en produit l'eau
d'érable l'eau des rams et la sève qui
coule dans l'érable donc la seule est un
produit plutôt instable en fonction de
la température
et du temps essentiellement l'eau
d'érable plus dégradée si on veut vivre
à la maison comme vianney rabhi hier il
faut que l'eau d'érable doit soit donc
récolter rapidement soit fitri avec des
filtres alimentaire et soit transporté
rapidement dans les usines qui vont nous
permettre de l'embouteiller selon les
standards de l'industrie agro
alimentaire
ça se voit combien dans les épiceries ça
va de 3 dollars à 4 dollars 68 rock
faire en place longue et tango
différence voilà actuellement au québec
y à peu près une quinzaine de
producteurs faucons à se résoudre'
producteurs là il faut identifier les
usines qui vont embouteillé le produit à
l'heure actuelle de quatre à cinq usines
qui peuvent le faire donc il faut
coordonner la production le transport
par camion citerne désaltérante
l'époque où il échappe
ce truc
le sirop d'érable est vraiment vraiment
diminué un peu moi je garde les noix de
coco ou encore la sensation de mode coco
c'est vrai certifie natixis ça veut dire
quoi ça c'est une certification en fait
qui assure que c'est un produit 100%
peut que l'eau est intégral dont elle
n'a pas été altérée qu'elle est
également stérile dont il n'y a aucun
danger au niveau agroalimentaire et
forcément elle est naturelle victoire
lequel de préférer le côté yeux mais
comme les choisir et vous est ce qui
fait du sport parce que oui je fais pas
tu vois on a des allégations commission
de se maquiller sport évidemment c'est
l'eau d'érable contient peu de sucre
mais son compère a de nouveau à sombre
pour sportifs c'est trois fois moins de
sucre donc c'est plus intéressant de
cette façon là en même temps quand on
fait du sport on veut une certaine
concentration truc donc ici on utilise
l'eau d'érable parce qu'on préfère le
goût on va devoir ajouter un petit peu
de sucre faut rajouter un peu de sel
aussi parce que poste suffisamment de
sodium par rapport à ce qu'on veut aller
chercher dans un contexte de sports
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
d'eau
savez râble j'écoute pas vraiment non
non moi j'écoute en arrière où enseigne
agente parce qu'ils préfèrent des choses
moi se creuse ou qui étaient de plus en
plus écrit mais j'ai l'impression que
c'est peut-être parce que c'est un geste
rohff a ravivé l'eau d'érable contient
beaucoup de polyphénols antioxydants
certains minéraux ou si certaines
vitamines
je pense qu'on devrait s'intéresser à sa
teneur en cuivre ou en manganèse on n'a
pas besoin d'eau sucrée pour aller
chercher ces minéraux l'heure on aime
beaucoup parler du côté antioxydants de
l'eau d'érable en sirop d'érable
par contre tu une concentration qui est
très très minime
ici en tout cas à landos et on voit
réhydratation naturel avec électrolytes
lui rien d'avantageux nécessairement là
dedans on n'a pas besoin d'électrolytes
haut que ce qu'on trouve naturellement
dans l'eau
ça goûte vraiment comme l'érable
c'est bon je suis surpris de c'est un
peu comme
le caramel et toi sont délicieuses
entente elle mais pour moi et bout été
prononcée de ce côté c'est simon l'eau
d'érable en fait quand on dit qu'en
moyenne le taux de sucre et de 2.2 pour
ça ça peut varier de 1.9 jusqu'à trop en
fonction de la journée de production
encore une fois on est dans la nature de
la nature c'est pas une usine standard
donc il ya des journées où ça peut être
un peu plus sucré d'autres journées un
peu moins sucré et en a marre sur les
contenants ils ont tous le même ton au
dessus lui un petit peu moins de sodium
un peu comme d'une pomme un autre pomme
le groupe varie d'un camion à un autre
camion le goût peut aussi varier parce
que forcément c'est un produit brut de
la nature donc on n'est pas en train de
moderniser ou de stade à vie un goût on
est là pour amener le goût tels qu'ils
le couler en date d'aujourd'hui c'est ça
c'est local puis puisse et je pense que
c'est dans juste pour ça c'est plus
intéressant que lou noix de coco boys
même si aujourd'hui c'est l'eau d'érable
mais patrick ici largement démarqué
demain la semaine prochaine dans un mois
le résultat pourrait complètement
différent parce que rappelons nous que
le dernier mot c'est la nature qui
l'aura sur le goût de l'eau